JASON SILVA: The famed
physicist, Freeman Dyson,
wrote about a very
near future, where
a new generation of
artists will be writing,
composing genomes
with the fluency
that Blake and
Byron wrote verses,
with the fluency of Shakespeare.
In other words, our new
alphabet, our new technology,
our new canvas is life itself.
The software of
biology, genetics,
mastering the information
processes of biology
turns the substrate
of life itself
into the raw material
for minds to engage with.
Talk about a recursive loop.
Talk about us folding
in on ourselves.
Mind has now
transcended its biology
enough to turn around and start
to tweak its own compositions.
I mean talk about the
evolutionary process,
slingshotting and evolving
its own evolvability.
Biotechnology makes us as gods.
As Stewart Brand
said, "We are as gods
and should finally
get good at it."
We ought to realize that
we are the music makers.
We are the dreamers of dreams.
We cast the spells.
We invoke the songs.
It's up to us.
This is our moment.